all right let's go to our first caller
today at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 we're gonna
go to the 6 4 6 area code
listen for your area code 6 4 6 go ahead
hi David um my name is I'm Dominique and
ami I'm a French girl from near city
living in Oklahoma and one day I will
call you back and tell you how
brainwashed the people here in Oklahoma
are ok
but today I want to talk to you about
something you said about Alexandria or
cardiac or Alexandria or Concha Cortez
yep I agree with you Ben your assessment
don't heart but I do feel that what
you're missing or maybe not taking into
account is modern democratic socialism
is a little different from street
democratic socialism do you remember
there was a not a party but a group
called the Social Democrats of America
yes well that's no longer exists if you
look it up online you can't find that
organization anymore part of the reason
they don't exist is because the
Democratic socialists of America now
have some capitalists ideas within their
platform and the capitalist ideas they
have are the ones that you talk about
mixed in with social democracy and with
democratic socialism for example I
believe the post office should be
socialized in 50% of the income goes to
the workers and I think in some things
actually it would work David so I would
like your feedback on it yeah if I can
take it piece by piece so first and
foremost so in my analysis where I said
there's a lot of confusion here between
democratic socialism and social
democracy to be super clear number one I
said that there are some who would argue
that the definitions of these things
have merely changed but then our
definitions worth anything anyway right
so so by by what we are understanding to
be the difference between social
democracy and democratic socialism I had
not heard Alexandria Cassio Cortez
actually a
democratic socialist beliefs and that
was sort of an open question at the time
now we can say well and I agree what it
means has shifted okay well then I guess
we need to redefine some terms right
okay good
now as far as you saying you think that
it might not be a bad idea to socialize
the post office in my analysis and which
I did I think it was like two days after
the story about Alexandra Cassio Cortez
I made clear that while I am NOT a
socialist or a Democratic Socialist but
I am a social democrat I said that I
actually do think that the idea of
socializing at the individual
organization level isn't a bad idea and
it's absolutely something that I'm
supportive of individual businesses
making as wonderful themselves the the
difference was I didn't say what I'm not
in favor of is that being a top-down
dictate as to how businesses must be
organized right right you can't take
away private businesses and then
socialize them and then basically I then
you could say steal their money it's
kind of not fair if the company belongs
to somebody you can't just take it away
from them and make it a public company
that's my belief although although some
things we disagree socialist would
disagree with it
right strict socialists would but
remember the Democratic Socialist today
I have don't believe in doing that what
they believe in
is democratic socialism mixed in with
social democracy okay well then I guess
they're not they're not really
socialists per se in that case Dominique
we're new it's a combination they
identify social because I think what the
idea is money should not be more
important than people so basically you
have to prioritize making sure
everybody's taken care of and nobody's
being wronged you get what I'm saying I
do and I think there's many Social
Democrats who who would sort of have
have the same view
Dominique I've got to go I just wanted
to know where New York City area from
well I'm actually from Manhattan and I'm
French and I grew up in in Paris and New
York City but I I now live in Oklahoma I
will call you back and you you will I
don't think she'll be shocked but the
brainwashing in Oklahoma
is a random I don't think I will be
shocked you're right about that I really
appreciate the call thank you so much
great to hear from Dominique from New
York City but now in Oklahoma